en tant de souvenirs de raul gainsbourg
nicole v dresse sont naturellement
chargée d'anecdotes et c'est sans doute
par une anecdote aussi qu'on peut
présenter ce personnage extraordinaire
oui c'est il n'a fait que vivre des
anecdotes presque s'entend très grasse
bon enfin en 2001 raul gainsbourg est
quelqu'un qui a été à la fois musicien
écrivain collectionne hauteur de balai
chorégraphe directeur de perdre et qui
toutes sortes d'anecdotes sur son
enfance en effet qui montre bien qu'il
était il est né en roumanie dans une
petite communauté juive très pauvre de
roumanie et où il dit que pour montrer
qu'on avait bien dîné chez soi crop bien
souvent c'était pas vrai le grand chic
était de s'asseoir sur la porte de sa
masure et de se curer longuement les
dents pour que les gens d'en face on
travaille bien manger vie avec notre
anecdotes qu'ils racontent les enfants
là bas était donc est entré pour son
devait se contenter souvent de manger
juste une poignée de cerises comme ça
devant l'école est alors un jour et
passer quelqu'un qui avait le droit de
poser des questions aux enfants ce que
c'est un rabbin ou un policier ou un
professeur et il a dit au petit raul
petit raul pourrait ce que fait tout et
camara dimanche le mauvaise cerise
d'abord et garde les bonnes pour la fin
quand ça c'est plus agréable toi qu'est
ce que tu fais tu commences par les
bonnes et raul a répondu vous et c'est
que moi les mauvaises je ne les mange
jamais et toute sa vie et là il n'a pas
rangé livret cerise et il a choisi ce
qui était bon ce qui était jolie ce qui
était amusant c'est un lieu charmant
prodigieux plein d'histoires en russie
en france gaz doit vraiment connu tout
le monde vraiment tout le monde est beau
tout le monde il a notamment recueilli
les confidences de tolstoï sur wagner où
ça déjà avoir stagné n'avait pas reconnu
tout le reste du monde il va voir tome
style et instinct lui dis bah oui wagner
c'est du bon opéra je ne dis pas c'est
peut-être de la bonne musique mais c'est
de la bien mauvaise
tes ratures et ça m'a fait penser au
cinéma enfin si tolstoï avait vu le
cinéma en ce moment ils auraient
peut-être dit que c'était du bon cinéma
mais cela bien mauvaise idée puis parle
aussi d'une visite à wagner à olemps
bravade mère déjà âgée maquiller plein
de blanc de garm avec des dentelles et
un jeune homme vous êtes même affolé de
voir ce génie comme ça c'est efféminé et
alors l'année est d'ailleurs enfin une
excuse que peut donner qu'un génie ou
ceux du je suis un peu vieux n'est-ce
pas alors ça m'arrange avait été
complètement maquiller presque 2010 et
enfin un certain déjeuner chez sarah
bernhardt mérite aussi d'être évoquée
d'ailleurs une page sur les femmes
fatales
sarah bernhardt oui c'est à voir sarah
bernhardt à l'époque où elle jouait
phèdre health enfin de jouer en russie
et tout d'un coup il raconte c'est vrai
que l avait mis six jours et six nuits
sans wagon lit pour aller en russie je
ne sais pas ce qu'en penserait silvia
monfort qui est allé en russie il ya pas
si longtemps dans des conditions
autrement confortable c'était quand même
dur bien qu'il ait vu des wagons ou pour
les gens qui voulait voyager en bout
déjeuner chez sarah bernhardt ça se
passe à l'heure à paris à un gainsbourg
qui avait fait un article sur sarah
bernhardt à son voyage en russie
la revue à paris a lui dû éviter donc
déjeuner il a déjeuné libé reçus au
louvre la porte pas de sarah bernhardt
et pas de coup vers 12h30 1h 1h30 2h pas
de sarah bernhardt pas de gouverner et
finalement elle descend et la diversité
de la faune loi mais on vient de
s'apercevoir que tout mon argent tri et
au mont-de-piété je compatis une grande
actrice mme que ça arrive sur les armes
fatales oui je vous êtes un nom il dira
à rencontrer des danses slaves titré en
ce sens plusieurs qui lui ont dit que le
seul plaisir qu'il pouvait avoir dans la
vie c'était de voir des hommes se tuer
pour elle et alors c'est vraiment de
rêve il ya eu des en effet des ambitions
se suicider pour vous mais ça vous a
vraiment fait beaucoup de plaisir et en
dit plus seul plaisir
peillon dans la vie c'est que des hommes
ce tournoi là par terre et j'ai cherché
alors là j'ai relu trois fois ce passage
pour comprendre je me suis dit que
peut-être souvent les gens se font
prendre au tragique parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à se faire prendre au
sérieux enfin il me semble que c'était
une femme qui se faisait pas l'inde
heures des personnages célèbres dont il
est question dans la chaque page peut-on
dire que ce livre a des qualités
les mérites littéraire certains
d'alluré monde y est finalement oui au
début on se dit bon c'est très joli ce
sont des anecdotes ce monsieur a vécu
très longtemps il est mort il ya trente
ans il a tout vu et connu tout le monde
et puis on s'aperçoit que c'est très
joliment racontée que là encore il a
fait lui l'histoire des bonnes frites et
de malaisie
tous les paragraphes sont très courts ça
s'arrête et un petit blanc le temps de
jeter les mauvaises cerise et de
reprendre les bonnes et ça finit par
avoir une allure étonnante et je crois
que c'est parce que cet homme avait du
goût ce qui est très bien et puis du
flair
[Musique]